on the streets of New Orleans messages
of support for those on the front lines
of the coronavirus medical staff barely
have time to read the signs the city is
dealing with one of the worst outbreaks
of the virus in the u.s. the strain on
local hospitals is so acute a convention
center will take in those with less
severe symptoms it tends to be what we
call supportive care and it's things
like oxygen and getting out of bed and
walking around and staying well hydrated
there aren't any specific medications
that that cure somebody of this illness
despite testing both in labs and at
roadside locations the virus continues
to ravage the city death rates per
capita in the New Orleans area around
pacing those of New York city officials
say hospitals will soon be a breaking
point
and so far the virus has hit one
demographic particularly hard slightly
more than 70 percent of all of our
deaths are among African Americans who
make up about 32 percent or so of the
overall population of our state so
obviously this is a big disparity and
we're gonna try to figure out what that
is attributable to and what we can do
about that as quickly as possible
despite warnings some religious leaders
in the state continue to hold services
faster London Spradlin who criticized
hysteria over the virus was in New
Orleans for Mardi Gras where he preached
on the streets after spending eight days
in intensive care he died of kovat 19
it's thought he contracted the virus in
New Orleans in a city with high rates of
heart disease obesity and diabetes the
worst is yet to come
doctors say they're bracing for hard
times in the coming days the hospital's
been slowly filling up and we're waiting
for that point of where we hit the
critical mass and then then it's gonna
be the next phase we're gonna have to
try to figure out how to handle that
issue dr. la bas and his team are doing
what they can to get ready for the
coming storm the next few days may prove
more challenging than anything New
Orleans has faced before
Andy Gallacher al Jazeera